welcome everyone this is part four in
our series on presenting your research
we're going to be talking about the
possibly thrilling and possibly
nerve-wracking process of giving a
conference talk in our field
let's start with the basic structure of
a talk this is pretty easy
it's probably going to mirror the
structure of papers in our fields but
the thing to keep in mind is that the
talk narrative has to be dramatically
simpler
the beginning should start just like a
paper does and just like an abstract
does you need to answer questions that
involve context what problem are you
solving
why is the problem important what's been
tried before and why wasn't it a full
solution these things will contextualize
your results and set your audience up to
be prepared for the contribution that
you're about to offer
that will happen in the middle you'll
give concrete details about what data
you used and then crucially what
approach you took and what its details
are up to the level of detail you can
supply in a talk like this and also
information about your metrics how do
you evaluate success these concrete
details will constitute your proposal
and they're really crucial
and then in the final part of the talk
you'll offer results in the form of
tables and graphs and so forth and you
might review some aspects of the
analysis from your paper what worked and
what didn't
what work still needs to be done and
things like that and then crucially at
the very end you should be sure to
articulate
what you achieved in the work and why
it's significant the idea is to leave
the audience with information that will
compel them
to take the time and energy to read your
actual paper for the full details on
your contribution and then that way the
talk will serve as an effective
advertisement for the underlying project
now you can read lots of advice on the
internet about how to give effective
talks in various contexts and i would
encourage you to seek it out because
some of it might really align with your
style you should keep in mind though
that styles differ and context differ
and so this will be a process of
figuring out what advice is really
suitable for you
the one thing that i can say with
confidence is that patrick blackburn's
fundamental insight will apply no matter
what the context and what the style
patrick blackburn asks where do good
talks come from and his answer is
honesty he says a good talk should never
stray far from simple honest
communication and if you abide by that
and you're introspective about where
you've achieved open honest
communication and where you felt short
in various talks that you give and
you're willing to learn from that
process you will definitely find your
style and become an effective
communicator about scientific ideas
according to what works best for you
a note about powerpoint you can find
lots of think pieces about how
powerpoint and related slide
technologies are inherently kind of evil
i think they can be used to confuse and
deceive but they also have lots of good
aspects to them and it's not an accident
that slides are pretty pervasive when
giving talks in our field and it's just
a matter again of finding your style and
thinking about how to use these slides
for open honest communication
in that vein and again this is a matter
of personal style i thought i would
mention two kind of schools of thought
when it comes to slide design the
minimalist and the comparative
so the minimalist would probably just
have two words on this slide a
minimalist and comparative and the rest
would be delivered via a talk track the
idea behind the minimalist approach is
slides should be as spare as possible
the audience should spend most of their
time listening and listening to you and
looking at you
and individual slides don't stay up for
very long or get used in more than one
way their kind of punctuation for your
narrative talk track
by contrast the comparative approach
would be you have lots of details on
your slides slides should be as full as
possible without sacrificing clarity
your talk should make it easy for people
to spend time studying your slides you
have to think about how your narrative
is going to align with the very detailed
slides and individual slides might stay
up for a long time and get used to make
multiple comparisons and establish
numerous connections
i want to emphasize again that this is
really a personal matter the minimalist
view seems right for telling a story
it's often the best mode when time is of
the essence and the audience is mainly
there to learn about what your paper
contains
whereas the comparative view seems right
for teaching right it's the closest that
the slides can come to full well and
organized chalkboards and things like
that where a lot of information might
stay up for a very long time
fundamentally though this is a matter of
style find the version that works for
you for the context you're in and i'll
just say again as long as you think long
and hard about what it would be like to
listen to your talk that is the open
communication part and you adjust
accordingly i'm sure that you'll shine
no matter what approach you choose
i really like slides when it comes to
using them to guide audience attention
and help people follow the narrative of
your talk track one fundamental thing
that you can do for that is make heavy
use of overlays overlays might allow you
to fill a slide with information in that
comparative mode while steep still
keeping the audience with you as you
make individual points you can also use
color systematically on slide to create
distinctions and highlight different
pieces of information if you use it
consistently then people will figure out
that you're using color for one concept
and that will really help them key into
the structure of your ideas pick an
accessible color palette and then this
can really be your friend when it comes
to communicating with an audience
you can also use size to draw attention
to things and boxes and arrows and other
devices to help people navigate
especially complex information displayed
on your slides this is incredibly useful
when you are for example displaying a
figure of results to have boxes as
overlays on the individual comparisons
and results that you want to highlight
same thing for a model diagram you could
show the whole model diagram and then
use boxes to highlight in different
pieces of information in the diagram as
you talk about them in your narrative
talk track and that can be incredibly
valuable when it comes to helping people
navigate what would otherwise be a very
complicated looking slide
of course you could offer the
information that i just delivered in the
more minimalist version this would be
like overlays color
size boxes and arrows and so forth
for particular styles that might be
exactly the right mode to talk about
guiding audience attention you can
probably see that it's not really my
style but it's certainly a valid style
it can be very effective
some more mundane things
turn off any notifications that it might
appear on your screen if you're on up in
front of an audience of hundreds of
people and we see a notification about a
friend's email well it will certainly be
an entertaining thing for your audience
to have seen but it might not be
something that you wanted to be part of
your talk
make sure your computer is out of power
save mode so that the screen doesn't
shut off while you're talking
projectors can be finicky and even one
time of you losing your screen could
cause you to lose the projector and burn
through a bunch of the time that you
have allotted for your talk and that
could be really sad
shut down running applications that
might tax your computer or otherwise get
in your way again with notifications and
things like that
make sure your desktop is clear of files
and notes that you wouldn't want the
world to see you know in this day and
age your desktop might flash for a
second before the slides come up and for
you all you know this talk is going to
end up on youtube for the whole world to
see so think about the privacy aspects
of this
if you're using powerpoint or keynote or
google slides or something like that
create a pdf as a backup if your program
failed or the internet failed you might
not have access to your primary version
having a pdf backup will certainly be
helpful
and be prepared for the worst case what
if the projector fails you might really
be glad that you're prepared to give the
talk without any slides imagine that
scenario the audience will be on your
side in the presence of such a failure
of technology and it could be really a
chance for you to shine and the one
thing i'll say is that if you're
prepared genuinely prepared to give your
talk without slides the resulting talk
will be better because the narrative
part of your talk will be so much
stronger
finally the discussion period which
could be an exciting discussion period
or the most dreaded part of this whole
process
it's an important part of your
presentation though
it should be a chance for the audience
to gain a deeper understanding of your
ideas and when the discussion period
actually has that aim it's really a joy
and it feels like you and your audience
are moving forward together
sometimes other things happen though you
could get a hostile question or a
confused questioner or something even
more chaotic be ready for this and just
try to remain on even keel no matter
what happens
when you get questions after each one
take a pause for a second before
answering this will serve two functions
first you'll make sure that the person
has actually finished asking their
question which i think is socially
useful and second it will just make you
appear more deliberative which is good
so even if you know exactly what answer
you want to give taking the pause will
create a good impression on your
audience
avoid where possible saying i have no
idea in response to things and leaving
it at that
if you truly are floored you might say i
have no idea but let's think about the
following other considerations there
might be cases where you actually just
want to say i have no idea and leave it
at that but i think that that should be
used very sparingly
most questions won't make total sense to
you you have to remember that your
questioner doesn't know the work as well
as you do they might have lost track of
some of the details or gotten distracted
for a moment the question might not
completely make sense you'll feel
victorious though
if you can warp every question you get
into one that makes sense and leaves
everyone with the impression that the
questioner raised an important issue
again that's another way that you can
create a collective feeling that the
discussion was productive and as a group
kind of move the ideas forward as part
of this discussion period that's when
this is really exciting and you should
do everything you can to strive for such
moments knowing though that things could
go really awry and don't try to
internalize those too much either this
is a messy process but fundamentally i
think it can be quite rewarding in the
end